when fans do get to meet you what's the
most common questions they fire at you
what do you always get asked by people
how gross them how grossed out am i by
the dissection of bodies the autopsies
that I have to do that's the big one
and what's your response to that I'm not
very grossed out only the insects freak
me out but otherwise it's fun what do
you think that makes bones so special
that it's been going for such a long
time and has a huge fan base oh I I'm
guessing you probably I think it's the
cast the interaction that's sort of odd
balance between procedural like grim
procedural stuff and this odd sort of
personal relationship ursin elationship
that happen and the comedy that sort of
manages to filter through I think it's
just a bizarre balance
do you understand much of the science
stuff you know over the years we've
actually acquired a little bit of
knowledge because you start to sort of
get familiar with certain things you
know after seven years
obviously is quite procedural tons I was
just saying it's it's interesting
because I you don't I don't think we
realized it until like you know well
into like third or fourth season we are
practical joking all the time dancing in
between takes laughing all the time and
I think it's probably not only do we get
along that I think it sort of helps keep
us from sort of being aware of how grim
what it is we do you know what we're
dealing with every day is I mean talking
about the rest of the cast what did
David and Emily really like I mean we
going to love these characters and we've
seen them both on screen for such a long
time now but what do they like when the
camera's not rolling when the camera's
not rolling David likes to he likes fart
machines and he likes to spank things
and say BAM that's his like that's his
big thing everything whether it's like a
corpse foot or you know so he's usually
he's the practical joker and Emily is
probably the sweetest person on planet
earth I'm in terms of David's practical
jokes he'd been never been a victim of
any particular memorable ones fart
machine he got me with the fart machine
which I you can see clearly it scarred
me because
it's uh I sat down I don't know whether
it was an Emily's office and it was like
a nice gigantic bad wet one he got yeah
he got me good because when you say
Emily is one of the nicest people on the
planet what makes her so amazingly sweet
the fact that she is amazingly sweet
she's just she's thoughtful she knows I
mean I know it sounds silly but she
knows every crewmembers name she knows
their family she you know remembers
birthdays she's just she says please and
thank you like she and I know this
sounds very basic but you know she goes
out of her way to make sure that
everybody is taken care of which is a
very thoughtful cool thing to do I mean
talking about cool things obviously the
show has been running for such a long
time now we've had so many episodes and
fans have their favorites for you
personally is there any that looking
back we're especially proud of or just
have especially fond memories of making
I had fun with arastoo's parents and I
also I I had fun with the identity theft
storyline that was really fun for me to
do so the show's been obviously running
for quite a long time now what would you
like to see next season happening man
hey well you know cam did develop
developing maybe a drug habit going to a
mental institution no I don't know
there's like we haven't there's not much
we haven't covered so I don't know where
the writers are gonna go I mean
obviously each character brings their
own element to the show for you
personally what do you feel you bring to
the show what do I bring to the show I
think I bring an appreciation cam seems
to bring an appreciation of her team you
know that and I think the audience sort
of shares that in that appreciation so
the writers kind of always describe me
as being like the audience the eyes and
ears of the audience like I witness my
the Jeffersonian team the way you know
you know our fans would would you like
to get out of the lab more I love
getting out of the lie actually here's
the fun we have so much fun doing the
experiments in the lab that you know
it's it's great to be there and it's an
i it's an awesome set but you know TJ
and I are getting out all
lotmore and it's always fun to be like
at the bottom of a well or be in the
middle of a field finding some grisly
gruesome body you know and I always take
pictures and say mom just another day at
the office you know I get to send them
to her
was there a particularly memorable death
ooh oh okay it hasn't aired yet you guys
haven't seen it but we find a very
blown-up charred guy in in an Airstream
that's pretty funky you're pretty funky
he's just kind of everywhere and this
the goal ever bother you um I think
because our special effects guys the
Jaeger brothers are so good at what they
do we never imagined when you read it
you can never imagine just how gory it's
gonna be until you get there but thank
goodness it smells like prosthetics it
smells like rubber so you know you're
not dealing with anything real so mostly
I'm just fascinated by it
I mean what's been the most fascinating
thing that you've got to poke around
with um well I've gotten to do some
pretty gruesome stuff I'm there was one
description I had to I had to slice open
a skull I had to saw open a skull remove
the skull can but peel back the face
that was pretty grisly remove the skull
cap take out the brain and slice it like
carpaccio is how they described it in
the script that was pretty grisly what
was the most emotional episode you
filmed wow that's a toss-up I'd say um
Zach the Zach
gormogon episode was pretty emotional
for me and I think
Arastoo being poisoned was pretty
emotional I mean what is it about this
kind of world that you think fascinates
people so much why what why is it such a
constant source of excitement Horace
Mann
you know I wonder I think I I think
humans we are fascinated with mortality
you know we are so very alive I think
mortality were still curious and
mystified by it
you know in all of its forms so I I
don't know if we'll ever run out of run
out of that particular curiosity of
course I mean you very rarely get a
chance to play a character for as long
as you have I mean what does that give
you as a performer that you don't get
when you just get kind of one shot in a
film or a kind of a one-off episode it's
it's almost like doing theater a little
bit because you we've lived with these
characters for so long you actually
discover and it's funny because the
writers sort of I attribute a lot of
this to the writers they start to add
dimensions and layers as the seasons go
on so we're discovering the characters
you know along with the fans which is
kind of interesting and fun and the
puffs from you or do you have a favorite
character in the show I really loved
Vincent nigel-murray I think he was
pretty he was I'm not gonna say my
favorite squintern but I just thought he
was pretty brilliant and his death was
so sad on a happy note what else have
you got coming up in the moment or else
we're gonna see my bones of keeping this
for all pretty busy so aside from like
getting to pop over here for a minute
I'd go back to work in a month and where
we at with bones in the cycle where are
we gonna get kind of more of that you
say you're going back in a month
yeah the writers are back I think in a
week and the actors are back in a month
and then we start season 10 final
question you got a message for fans
before you leave us thank you so much
for watching we have so much fun doing
it and I'm glad that you all appreciate
watching it
you